bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ed era un
[ __ ] secolo che non iniziamo con una
intro normale
grazie a dio sono sussulti siamo in due
oggi è una barca molto piccola molto una
zattera siamo io e tom oggi cerchiamo di
fare una cosa in particolare
non so se avete visto la live che ho
fatto domenica scorsa e ciò non avete
visto la rai seguitemi tutte le
domeniche alle due e mezza alle sette e
mezza questa era uno sponsor interno al
video non è un placement e un fa vj's
mente ragazzi siamo io e tom che in
questo punto non sta parlando si gratta
la schiena e dobbiamo cercare di ma
piove quat
niente scherzi non si muove è diventato
solo muto ed è quindi un pirata vero
cioè nel senso uno è sordo 1 e muto ed è
purtroppo va beh a puoi suonare però va
bene suona stonato
ripeto se non avete visto la mia live
che ho fatto domenica scorsa sempre con
tom e con pietro e c'era anche stormi
abbiamo tentato di battere delle navi
nemiche c'è veramente queste barche
fatte a scheletro bisogna a buttarne giù
10 se riesce a buttarne giù 10 prendi un
bottino della madonna non ci siamo
riusciti in quattro oggi tenteremo di
riuscirci i due c'è uno e mezzo perché
un e mutu già partiamo benissimo che
equa piove quindi la partenza direi che
degli dei
la barca sta già fondando a prescindere
predire io vorrei porta sfiga
adesso vado sotto la coperta ecco lo
sapevo stavo già fondando fianco
io non ho mai fatto rai entrati o del
chiodato del muto del tutto da niente
nero io avrei problemi
stava parlando no ero io il problema
ok la partenza da dio va bene allora
senti un attimo siccome l'ultima volta
che ci abbiamo provato siamo rimasti a
secco di palle di cannone io proporrei
di trovare palle di cannone sia su
quest'isola che su altre eventualità
guarda che venga svuotata l'isola e
tutti i materiali che aveva davvero
invece noi hanno appena trovato in bot e
svuotato malaja vista criticando aia
no non è vero no valutare la dovessi
essere più veloce storici di lei scoma
bo e allora come si fa a fare questa
cosa che vogliamo fare dobbiamo trovare
l'olandese volante che presente sarebbe
stanare che vola sul serio se c'è una
nave che vola e una nuvola e noi
dobbiamo provare quella credo che non so
quando e che spunta una nave davanti a
noi mio mosso
ma non ai ci scaldiamo nassi vediamo
beqaj è sì scaldiamo i cannoni che bello
ci sono ora che mira è attenzione
devo girare a destra il capitano stiamo
per andare
ma ci sono anche dei barili quindi
possiamo prendere un po di palle di
cannone is easy
nel frattempo che sfruttato deve
spuntare la barca e obi tratta dai ke
skifo faccio o una mossa tattica mio
capitano si faceva stiamo andando
esattamente lì va bene andiamo a trovare
let's go by prego ora butto l'ancora e
ora possiamo sparargli col cannone e io
sono prescelti centro sparati tu col
cannone io vado vedere cosa hanno
sta arrivando il tizio dei casi l'ho
preso una volta sta per salire sulla
nave dall'isola da bisogna solo nostra
ma preso una volta sta salendo le scale
adesso lo vedo lo vedo è salito mi
sapore d'altri cielo non lo vedo queste
salito dal retro nono titolo basta morse
non stanno affondando proprio di bestie
se non allocati a rivaldo e non credo
adesso sto aspettando che vadano più si
sparano tu e attenzione affondare la
nave così subito come riscaldamento
niente male
vediamo se c'è un qualcosa adesso le
basi di salire a galla tanto io prendo
palle di cannone acqua l'ultimo pezzo di
terra destra c'è una cassa l'haka ne dà
una mano
una casa che male ai a sé vola e non c'è
ancora traccia dell'olandese volante
male vita intera risolve l'enigma pare
mi dove sto andando
allora l'altra parte del mare su ciò che
il collo e sud est my friends sud est
vescovado la cascata sud est manda
regista cascata 1 2 3 6 8 e 9 qua
cos'è sta roba un forziere schifosissimo
tutto sto casino per una cagata del
genere ti stiamo attaccando se new york
senior si stanno inseguendo e stiamo
entrando nella tempesta bene una cattiva
notizia invece si balla veniamo a
[ __ ] il tentativo dell'olandese
volante e andiamo contro questi direi di
sì tanto finchè non spunta l'olandese ce
ne sbattiamo laici provo prove delle
tedesco a fermarli let's go my friends
allora ricapitolando chissenefrega
dell'enar dell'olandese volante capiterà
un'altra volta ma ci stanno seguendo e
noi non rifiutano mai la battaglia
perché siamo del club degli dei
attenzione sto per ingaggiare la nave ha
fatto un salto sembra tipo salve l'hack
è male
maya con tagliera ancora le antenne so
se ne sono accorti se ne sono accorti di
questa volta lei
un vero peccato va preso madonna che
mira l'ho preso da un chilo lui mi ha
colpito ma l'ho preso anche io
fortissimo vai ma tu ed abbiamo nei
nemici ragazzi sono i più grandi hanno
dei nemici
chissenefrega è una lotta all'ultimo
sangue e noi sangue remo si incarnano
giri giri tiri lang ore l'angolo la tiri
da che parte giriamo verso sinistra
ok vai ti ritiri tutto tiri tutelando
tirati ci proviamo
l'uomo loro sfera scarica la palla di
cannone manca tirando avanti
gli ho mancato di nuovo sono vado avanti
e proseguite mancarli chase è riuscita a
mancargli ci hanno incornato occhio che
vestigia saltano ma non ho colti ma non
ci credo
resisti resisti sono in casa sono in
casa ma si stroncato con la spada mi
avvicinavo
e morto mario rotella la quale arrivò
l'acqua l'acqua arrivi arrivi di una
mano e casinò qua c'è una madonna sabato
la nave all'ultima abbiamo tanti di quei
buchi madonna si stava imbarcando acqua
e confronto il titanic era bello solido
sia una mano cosa fa
guarda che casino provare che sono
stessi conti mandateci a secchiate
questo sì ci vuole ancora male ma io li
voglio più male prendi lo prendi l'onore
prendilo let's go è ancora molto miu miu
botta mi sa che le guidato generale no
ancora lì quasi facilissimo
attenzione mamma ci ho creduto madonna
che casino 16 10 ricordiamo è salvo si
no però io colpiti forte oggi sono il
via questo fa male non c'era esplosivo
di esclusivo veramente sicuro stava
salendo con l'esplosivo febbraio i
professori lo faccio fuori mi chiama
sono otto siamo saltati a si morto anche
tu no ok miglia in sé morivi anche per
un casino di serie sulla nave tour e non
solo sulla nostra che sta imbarcando
acqua e silvi sull isola 9 nostra tutto
se stessi tra questi la caccia vacca
mannaia sei stato bravo bravo bravo
mi piace avere dei nemici così bravo che
sfida il piace un sacco grande e così
eccomi qua un equa colpito la ucciso o
malamente ha tirato la vera lo colpiti
due volte no è attirato la ancora
maledizione sono risalito sopra saremo
sopra fortissimo e uno l'ho ucciso in
acqua meno la palla di cannone è stato
bellissimo
che male
grande senso stanno salendo sopra sì sì
c'era un tipo l'ho visto mi chiacchie
male gli abbiamo fatto tu beh è ancora
board ancora bordo come bordo la borda
muro d'acqua carità come a bordo non
muore
devo ricaricare le e morto cioè nei sei
anni a morire anzi cercando di girarla
arrivato morto ucciso così sporco
demonio sono scemi non l'hanno visto
l'isola sono fatte a svolgersi erano
troppo concentrati su di noi facendo
manovra stanno facendo manovra
allora io gli passò da dietro bravo
bertini con tutto sinis alto a sinistra
non passare da dietro tutto a sinistra
da sinistra grande e allora ecco le
manovre che fa ora dritto proviamoci c6
tom si ti voglio la carica palla di
cannone 1 e non sull'isola occhio che
sta provando a salire la elmo preparati
da quando ci penso io ci pensai a
buttarlo giù ci penso io
colpiti con la palla avvelenata
dobbiamo buttarla giù non guardare i
forzieri sto guardando i tesori solenne
tesori da rubare
questo sperimenteremo fatto male mi ha
buttato giù dello ci sono ci sono ucciso
progettino che è bravissimo vuota man
mano stanno guardando giù io e l'amico 6
e fratte armi siamo nel frattempo
nell'oltretomba
non ho ben capito che cosa stiamo
cercando di fare questi problemi è morto
let's go ce l'abbiamo fatta l'abbiamo
fatto i due oggi siamo bravissimi
complimenti questi erano in 3 2 contro
traviamento noi assurdo ma siamo stati
bravi oggi di successo sono riuscito all
e 438 grazie discorso lavoro non ha
detto ai ragazzi che s'era surtees spero
vi sia piaciuto perché abbiamo fatto un
sacco di problemi ammazzato gente
abbiamo fatto conoscenza abbiamo fatto
soldi tutto abbiamo fatto cosa dite vi
piace non mi piace anche se siete civile
possiamo video con thomas con chiunque
altro però passate alla lista grandi
thomas che vi lascio sempre in
descrizione bei ragazzi
[Musica]